the Channel Islands sit here just off
the coast of France and notably they
belong to the United Kingdom they were a
part of the duchy of Normandy which
England notably lost to France in the
early 13th century but the islands have
remained English and later British
thereafter which raises the question how
how did the British keep hold of the
Channel Islands for so long despite them
being so close to France to begin since
the 10th Century the Channel Islands
were considered to be a part of the
duchy of Normandy at that point under
the control of Duke Rollo a viking who
had basically turned up there and
blackmailed the king of France into
giving him the region later his
descendant William conquered England and
ruled both for separate entities and
this led to England and France's ruling
dynasties being tied to each other with
the kings of France demanding that the
Kings of England were also the dukes of
Normandy submit to them unsurprisingly
the English king said no and so
centuries of war in 1204 King John the
only infamously lost all of his
territories in northern France thereby
leaving the Channel Islands as the only
parts of Normandy still under English
Rule and 800 years later these islands
still don't belong to France so why well
it wasn't for a lack of trying John's
successor Henry III continued to war
against France without much success and
so in 1259 in return for him renouncing
his claim to Normandy the French King
Louis IX would renounce his claim to the
Channel Islands and would also recognize
the English king as the Duke of
Aquitaine after this piece obviously
reigned forever and by forever I mean
roughly 80 years later it was time for
the Hundred Years War during this and
the following Wars of the Roses the
islands were taken by the French and
retaken by the English numerous times
Pope sixtus IV because he couldn't stand
the French King issued a decree which
made the islands permanently neutral
something which was promptly ignored
when the French decided to conquer the
island a year later after this failed
both kingdoms agree to the Island's
neutrality and this lasted until the
late 17th century when William III
rescinded it because he had a war to
fight against the French and the Channel
Islands were great for raiding the
French Coast after this not much changed
until the Napoleonic Wars when Napoleon
briefly threatened the ownership of the
islands however British Naval Supremacy
meant that the French navy wasn't able
to protect the landing and also Napoleon
had much bigger problems and after the
war France's interest in retaking the
islands was minimal the new French
monarchy in later republics wanted to
keep Britain on site to act as a
potential ally against a rising Prussia
and so a few Islands weren't exactly
worth it furthermore in 1801 the British
Monarchy had forever renounced its claim
to the French throne and thus they
declared the Channel Islands to not be a
part of Normandy but a separate entity
under the British crown and given that
the Napoleonic wars were the last one in
which Britain and France ever fought
against each other there were no more
opportunities for France to take them
back I hope you enjoyed this episode
with a special thanks to my patrons
James bizonette Kelly moneymaker Sky
Chappelle katowitzka Andy McGehee Alex
Schwinn air Firefly Marcus Asner Spencer
Lightfoot wire hockey Marvin Castle
Captain psydog boogly Wiggly kamoon Yoon
Winston caywood Gustav Swan Khalid
Alderwood Maki Paskowski the macquapa
Anthony Beckett calling Dr Howard Dr
Fine Dr Howard Coppertone sherwenin
spinning three plates words about books
podcast Rod DeMar
and Charles the first